[Aplausos]
slide free soul y subir con su
vocabulario y códigos propios además de
su historia el skateboarding es a la vez
un deporte y un medio de expresión
tiene por supuesto cualidades deportivas
pero es también un modo de vida es una
cultura de vídeos grupos musicales
expresiones artísticas hay muchas cosas
de alrededor del skate no hay que verlo
como un deporte ciento por ciento sino
como una forma de pensar es decir cuando
comienzas a practicar skate no necesitas
de mucho sales de tu casa coges tu tabla
y te vas a hacer skate francia cuenta
con tres millones de skaters pero solo
3800 están afiliados a la federación sin
embargo todos comenzaron con una tabla
cuatro ruedas y el asfalto de la ciudad
como terreno de juego
es el lugar más divertido donde uno
puede liberar su creatividad probar
nuevas figuras y explorar el mobiliario
urbano
ruido aglomeraciones fuertes caídas al
comienzo el skate no era del gusto de
los vecindarios
[Música]
télam
y tú me haces clic en privado
incluso se ha llegado a prohibir su
práctica en ciertos espacios públicos
antes no éramos bienvenidos la gente no
entendía creían que nosotros solo
veníamos a hacer daños y por supuesto
eso no es así hoy el skateboarding es
ampliamente acogido y llega a los juegos
olímpicos con dos categorías el street
que imita el mobiliario urbano y el
parque o bowl con desniveles y curvas
para tomar velocidad y llegar a grandes
alturas
se les pide explorar lo que más puedan
los elementos del skatepark deben ser
fluidos se les pide técnica estilo en la
medida de lo posible y desempeño que sea
ya se ha escrito en farc hombres y
mujeres reciben una puntuación por cada
figura en tokio estarán en juego los
cuatro primeros títulos olímpicos en la
historia del skateboard